gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the group to be classy
yeah or they're just a big old piece of
trash I'm your hostage fully coming at
you on a thundering day boom out back
here at Toadies in the new edition it
feels nice and cozy fire going put a log
on not like a rainstorm in the
summertime amen sister Sweet Lord uh
Tony is done at the community center
okay yeah she volunteers once a week
it's good for her yeah my co-host is
coming at you from across the table this
is a family episode he is the CEO of Ru
garbage International
businessman business loves a flatbread
the flatbread freak KJ Kevin James Ryan
what up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube version of those numbers are
thank you very much Mr t-boner cooking
then obviously the greatest website of
all time www.patient are you garbage you
go over there you join the over 10 000
homies let's just say it over 10 000
homies on there a lot going on on the
patreon and we've got to toot our own
horns some of the best in the bid we are
cranking our County you can get up to
two episodes a week you get all the
bonus videos from the past two three
years it's a [__] party gang go check
it out for yourself yeah having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones the twos
the threes and the fours the fives and
the sixes sometimes it's T-Bone
mcgruffins it's Toby McMullen hey what's
up boys what up T-Bone you fixed the
quaff it looks good thank you very much
that was a that was a very smoky intro
like 1940s broadcaster a little bit yeah
yeah the thunderstorms they have invaded
and then the [__] lights are down I
don't know where you are but try to find
your loved ones I will be here well
ladies and gentlemen we have not seen
Tara I don't know
guys go to commercial
you know what I wanted to ask you it
just popped into my head what's that
have you ever have you ever had your
chain snatched what my chain snatched
whatever oh my jaw rule who gets their
chains snatched like that
you got real chain snatch face
I can see I did I I can see you high
school not high school with your jerseys
on out on the Wildwood Boardwalk at
night okay you have you have I just got
my chain snatched officer I'm crying
he was mean the reason why it popped
into my head but it did I gotta get that
back it was mostly Zing
the joke's on him that'll turn his neck
green
I don't know why uh I no it's never been
snatched there was a period you look
like a kid that would get robbed on the
boardwalk no and that's not an insult
well it's not a compliment I don't know
what to tell you what the [__] what's
Witness
comes in at my throat you have a bad 30.
this guy's all over the map that was a
good Tony a misdirection there's the
Thunder again
we went on a 1940s radio review I'm
talking about a missing girl yeah yeah I
wasn't good on that one uh okay
um I [__] that up
I was trying to think of something real
good
you guys want to take it from the top
ladies and gentlemen stay in your homes
we have not seen Terror like this there
is if there's a chain snatcher out there
um no I did I never got beat up on the
boardwalk uh I don't think I've ever
gotten in a fight on the boardwalk uh
that was it never got all all the board
was off the board have you ever been in
a fight yes you ever mix it up yeah
we've talked about this a bunch okay
yeah oh man it's just checking you yeah
don't start calling you [__] you want
to be in another one Ronnie the reacher
over here hey Jack Reacher
um
excuse me sir have you ever been beat up
um uh no but I did wear a chain with a
charm we called them charms back in the
day was that half a heart no it was a
dragon
uh that I got at the mall yeah it was
like a serpent dry you know like an s
dragon kind of it was very like Romeo
Must Die type stuff and he had like four
legs I think a tongue or a fire type
thing yeah that was fun and games to hit
red dragon territory yeah [__] come
rolling up on me four legs that's a dog
dude what are you talking about
uh why because I was a dork what do you
mean why hence why I asked you that you
got your chain snatched I mean people
aren't they weren't snatching chains in
junior high well you're right in a
principal's office for that we went out
in the streets I always tell you know I
mean snatching chains uh no it's charged
a chain a necklace and charms or what we
call them I was 13 or whatever everybody
had to have a cross or something you got
them at the mall they were like the
chain was probably 35 bucks and the
charm was probably 15 or something did
you collect them like the way moms did
and like yeah it wasn't a charm like
that I think that's just what we called
them it was like uh imagine like if you
know 50 Cent has the big crawl the big
gold cross a very small subtle verse
like tiny I'm picturing like a monopoly
piece no it was probably like this big
yeah Dad wasn't thrilled about Dragon
Dad wasn't thrilled yeah well all so you
know it was like you know when I get the
same one it's like someone had like a
cross and you want to get the you don't
want to be just like you know [__]
Pat had this or this so I had to go a
little uh you know a little martial art
style on them [__] can't be the
dragon coming at you yeah I was in my
proudest moment I only wore it uh I only
wore it for a little bit you know
special occasion oh God told got
snatched uh so it did get stolen no I'm
kidding I think I polished it too much
and then
the silver finish came off
it's plastic underneath yeah I would
clean it it was yeah that was clean yeah
I had like I stole my mom had like a
jewelry cloth I would clean I got to be
sharp dude I had to be fresh you seen me
I was cool back then what year are we
talking
two thousand two thousand two thousand
wearing yeah
dread just came out with the chronic for
the 99 2000 that was huge man when that
album dropped to effect he wasn't
wearing charm bracelets they had not
braces not a charm bracelet you have the
wrong picture in your head I think I got
the right picture no it was a cool
necklace that cool guys wore a lot
anything on this here you're his age he
was homeschooled he probably lost it
driving his Kawasaki on the highway with
his katana
was I in the club was I a prospect for
the Yakuza maybe all right I'm not I'm
not supposed to talk about it but I was
doing some deals okay I was an affiliate
couldn't fit in the suit
I don't have the jacket on just the ties
looks terrible in a skinny black box I
look like the waiter
I was like the waiter at a communion bar
caterer
carrying sternos that's Kevin he's the
waiter uh you call him Dragon wasn't my
uh wasn't my wasn't my proudest moment
okay like I said popped into my head
sure thought maybe you know in the Rough
and Tumble streets of Wildwood as a kid
you probably had a lip on you you're I
know you were slow
I was a [__] I was kept my I was afraid
of my own shadow I kept my head down in
[__] as a kid get like eight or nine
I got a 16 year old with a goatee a
mustache I [__] wasn't making eye
contact with him no way [__] wearing
a tank top
the [__] out of here dude
maybe a game of Skee-Ball Gateway 26 but
I ain't mixing it up with the [__]
the trash that's down there the
Hooligans oh man you don't want to scare
me as a kid the guy you would see right
if you were like 10 11 I was just always
afraid of anybody older than me an adult
whatever you know some of them are real
scary but the kid that was looking for
trouble the kid that had a tattoo that
wasn't 18 where like his mom signed off
on it or whatever you know they played
it real fast and loose in that household
it's a [__] single mom signing off
for a kid to get a tribal tattoo we got
the hanger every once in a while
they heat it up on the stove first too
and gave him a good whack I'm 15 year
old with a switchblade on arm yeah
something like that where you're like a
chip on his shoulder
look in a [__] tune-up pudgy over
here
that's my slice of Sam's well I'm sorry
yeah I I was afraid of everybody
especially at that young fat kid I
didn't want nobody looking at me uh uh
keep it moving head down ten and two
take Skippy's Pizza
um that never happened right never take
your lunch or anything like that I
didn't go I didn't go to school in sing
sing what do you take my lunch
is everything just an 80s movie with
bullies nobody's nobody ever really
stole anyone's lunch like that you ever
getting a ski race for the mountain
oh
do you ever ring the homecoming
elections what are you talking about no
do you ever like the most popular girl
in school but then found out the girl
that was your friend next to you was
really beautiful when she took her
glasses off and put her hair down I took
her to prom
yeah I know I didn't know I didn't grow
up and Saved by the Bell so okay it
happened but um
one thing I did I saw which was that's
funny it reminded me of these years of
those are very early teen years of me
rocking my my necklace what do they call
it I think they call it a piece now no
like a Jesus Piece but I think it is
would it be bigger than this oh yeah
oh really the chain was fatter too oh
yeah no it wasn't no Rinky Dink thing
this is uh that makes sense I went to
Jacob the Jeweler and got iced out
that's what happened Kippy came Kippy
came Frosty came back from rocking
robins
is that guy National one of them
I don't think so
uh if you're out there local
Philadelphia Jeweler Delaware Delaware
so I think that's where the Hub is so
you don't pay the sales tax on the
engagement rings you used to have a a
diamond in his beard a diamond his beard
seemed like a real prick to me
you show off
what are we doing here are you chewing
with that scratching your gums
go down on your wife came up with a
catchy uh jingle though Robins yeah
um but this reminds me I saw kids in the
park the other day uh uh smoking weed
like they do these young Hooligans
smoking doobies out of a [__] on a
[__] uh Coke can soda can really
which to me I we stopped doing like you
were able to get I can't imagine now not
being able to get your hands on papers
or a oneie or a blunt or something
because that [__] wasn't ready available
readily available in this in Bucks
County as a 13 year old a one-hitter in
the 90s you had to like send away I
thought they were for crack when the
first time I saw one I'm like yo what
are you my brother had one of those
dugouts with the little [__] sing I'm
like that thing that thing looks like
you'd be smoking ice out of that I
always kind of low-key hated those
wooden bug outs you didn't know when you
were hitting wood or not I don't know
what you were smoking it was always bad
weed in there somebody pulls one of
those things out I remember we were like
14 I just learned what it was I think
through my brother or maybe even younger
and then my buddy's dad remember the
wooden thing and they had yeah yeah they
all look the same yeah for The Listener
it was the Sig you filled a little two
there's a wooden container that had like
a metal Sig looking one hitter and then
you put like a little weed compartment
what do you think they're a bunch of
nerds I don't know I don't know
we could have [__] 13 year olds
listening these things are old school
baby no one's still rolling around with
a bat and a dugout
oh man so my buddy's dad came he's got a
headband on if he does
what's up man
right on dude yeah
yeah guy sleeps in a van sure
but uh
my buddy's Dad we were 13 14 I just
learned what it was my buddy's dad came
home with one in his pocket like didn't
think anybody was gonna know and I'm
sitting there he's [__] fried to the
gills
I'll smoke oh dude [__] eyes all
swollen and [__] I look in his lips [__]
like like out of a movie High probably
because you didn't smoke that much but
he just had like him and his boy he went
to the Sixers game or something he came
back lit like like a teenager high
crunched
I remember shooting basketball and he's
like let me see it and he was like
trying he was all [__] you know
probably smoking wet now that I look
better I stopped at felt the street
before the game yeah but I saw it I was
like oh that's when I had all him I'm
like yo your dad is your dad smokes weed
like PRI I was the first dad that I knew
that I was like oh your dad proper
smokes weed we just had one
yeah one or two I think we had yeah
just one but it was never outright you
would like we would like date like I
said we would like you'd go rooting and
you'd find you know you'd find something
didn't have to root too far sock drawer
boom
single dad
at work every day
go in there
easy case
there was a part try to be vague with
this a friend had a party I don't know
if I ever told this story a friend had a
party and uh
a lot of people went it was like no
there was no no kids were allowed like
you know what he was allowed at the
house like just parents only and we
would yeah and my family had gone and
with like some other friends of
France you know parents of ours friends
group okay but it was an outside it was
a it was a it was a ragtag group from
another
another way of life I think my mom well
my mom went for like a half hour had a
[__] you know had a white had a had a
white wine it was like I this ain't my
company I don't know if you told me I'm
gonna show you you think they were
driving motorcycles in the pool and
stuff it was like it was a real [__]
dudes are just squirting lighter fluid
in the fire pit
was a real [__]
passing doobies around I don't I think a
little bit so that's what we had just
assumed we found a spoon in the bathroom
the next day like a the [__] with
like bent nope not bent but it had a
bunch of yellow residue and it was in an
upstairs bathroom no reason to have a sp
and that was the first thing I remember
you tell me about it
stop hanging out here yeah this this is
a lot it's okay I need to powder my nose
just falling out of the bathroom
she's all yours if you want two days
later
I think there's an alcohol swab rolling
around here somewhere I was like I left
the needle on the toilet seat for you
yeah not great hey thanks rusty
rusty that guy's for sure Rusty
[Laughter]
ah yeah but
um
would you want to tell me no I saw the
kids smoking weed out of the [__]
soda can and that reminded me I only
ever did it two or three times it didn't
feel it was like my
first I made my second or third time
smoking weed I did it a lot and every
time I thought I was gonna get
Alzheimer's because that's what they
tell you the paint oh it was terrible it
was like I'm looking back even then I'm
like this ain't you know the first time
you spoke like excited like it's cool
whatever we're doing it after I was even
like this ain't good there we gotta you
know
it's pretty trashy
but now everything's more readily
available
[__] glass bowls everywhere yeah you
get them like gas stations yeah
also I don't think I think those kids
are about that life what
oh they probably wasn't weed no now that
I'm looking now I'm putting dude I got
my detective hat on you dork that's a
strange way to drink a soda
hey guys smoking reefer
you know we see he's a Dugout back in my
day [__] run my pockets snatch my
chain
uh the kids want the one hitter
yeah
um but yeah I uh what is what is the
weirdest thing I know there's never a
big weed guy was a big booze bag
documented well documented what was the
weirdest thing you ever smoked weed out
of that's probably up there the can yeah
apple was big when you were in a jam I
love an apple apple was big I feel like
T-Bones probably like smoked out of a
snorkel or something my brother's tube a
mouthpiece
[Music]
trumpet mouthpiece okay it's metal oh
yeah yeah did you tell him what
what are you like hey let's make this or
you just like I can smoke weed out
that's C sharp no more but
you leave the resident in there [__]
he's got a black circle around his lips
did you put it in that part and smoked
out of the
the bottom uh how did you pack a huge
Bowl in the trumpet and [__] hit it
bam except I would not never what never
never it doesn't work never out of the
trumpet which I regret so heavily now it
would have been like a cereal Bowl's
worth of weed
that's what I'm talking about the front
part go heavy bike now what you should
do is a trombone
pull that back in it's like pulling this
shoddy no I would you hear that bad I
would use it for the bowl for gravity oh
okay gotcha oh that's great all right
because that was always the biggest pain
in the ass about them finding the cap
that was the word we used yeah yeah we
got to make a cap we gotta make a cap
ratchet was big for us ratchet a ratchet
head for the cap that's good throw the
sing screen in there ratchet or
sometimes you would get like the big
socket like the long extender and you
would just put that and just [__]
I've also ripped the end of like a a
cable like hook up like for television
that little end with a screw you rip
that off that works wow oh yeah
man I'm crafty when I need a buzz
I don't know if these all right word
[__] Samson over here [__] rat
scare you know when you're shooting
through wires to get high
use my mom's contact lenses uh nothing
fair enough I had one buddy who would
hold a
he like undid a paper clip or something
and then would just hold the nug and
burn the nug and like
I mean like that's [__] you're out
there man we were we were 12 years old
Freebase and kind bud swiggetts dude
that was no gun that was no kind mother
that's he was doing that with seeds and
stems I never got into that the hot
knife on the on this electric stuff I
mean just [__] shoot heroin if you're
doing that that's where I'm at yeah the
Coke can and I [__] hated it every
time yeah it sucks I never really
[__] enjoyed it when I was a kid I
would just get massive [__] paranoia
massive oh that's why I stop I didn't I
mean like I said and then later on I'd
you know I'd like it but you still freak
out there was no no I'm saying every
time I smoke there was an hour of sheer
Terror sure and then you know okay let's
talk about that liquid IV they add up to
the liquid eye vessel real hard to
remember to drink your water especially
in the summer liquid IV makes a little
bit easier because it tastes great and
it hydrates you more than regular water
yeah I love it you know about when I was
sick man I was sucking that stuff down
like Mother's Milk baby shout out to
liquid IV my favorite is the fousey
Apple Crush that stuff I take it when I
have the Irish flu if you catch my drift
ah it's fantastic I love it uh getting
your daily dose of water has never been
easier just mix one stick of liquid IV
with 16 ounces of water and drink up I
got the whole fam hooked on it sure
everyone's crying I show up all the kids
like hey let me get that liquid IV it
hydrates you two times faster than water
alone and has three times the
electrolytes of leading sports drinks so
even if you've been on a crazy Bender
you can bounce back in time in in no
time for work on Monday real people real
flavor real hydrating now sugar-free
grab your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco
or get 20 off when you go to liquid.com
and use the code garbage at checkout let
our beak a little bit that's 20 off
anything you order when you use our
promo code garbage at liquid iv.com do
it gang yeah okay let's talk about
pretty litter ooh we eat a prettiest
litter inside in a Mississippi not only
a spokesman also a client yeah big man
loves it oh I love it what's a little in
his cereal it tells you where the kitty
cats got anything wrong with her because
it changes color on you and it's a real
work smarter not harder system yeah
because you can let you can let it go
along which scoop it out you're a big
procrastinator yes I am broom smells
fresh and clean you can really push the
limits one six pound bag of pretty
litter works for up to a month without
clumping so you can kick it down a road
a bit the ayg way baby uh pretty loaders
crystals also change color to indicate
early signs of possible illnesses sure
like UTI kidney issues and more so
you're able to act quickly when it when
it really matters and when you got a
sick you got a sick uh animal you gotta
you gotta stick and move it's Panic time
sometimes pretty litter has been the
best litter uh big man's ever used
you'll love it too go to
prettylitter.com garbage and use code
garbage to save 20 on your first order
that's pretty litter.com garbage code
pretty little.com one more time slash
garbage code garbage terms and
conditions apply see decipher details
links in the Bible do it a roll to join
out of a brown paper bag once
receipt paper
I watch my brother do and I was like
whoa you are you are dancing with the
devil now how long did you train hop
when you were a kid yeah it's real hobo
[__] yeah yeah it was all fun and games
until the dog died it's all [__]
crust Punk [__] you're doing what
happened to the dog got crushed by the
train
all those crossbone kids always have
dogs it's [__] up yeah and that is
[__] up I don't like it uh those guys
scare me oh yeah those Carhartt overalls
I'll take your life too sweet those
those guys think about getting your Jade
snatched [__] the death dealers those
two are those guys are yeah I don't [__]
with them no
um but uh we got a goddamn Family
episode gang do a couple of cues here
some patreon questions when you sign up
for the page I sound like a broken
record but you sign up for the patreon
answer your garbage question baby sign
up over there it's a good [__] time
it is and the homies they got home runs
what are we talking about here they do
the homies throw High [__] heat
homies and dingers dude they do man it's
like a goddamn Home Run Derby on that
thing uh all right this one's from
Travis very in the world perfect they
didn't even plan this this is the first
question pulled
uh ten dollar startup investor here
shout out to you is it garbage to be on
probation and Junior High
yes yeah for sure did you you were you
never got you never got you never got
snatched by the fuzz did you now either
did I got very lucky got a bunch of
times oh we gotta wait yeah we're like
my boys would get caught and just for
whatever reason they just forgot about
me or something nah nobody ever got
jammed up like that really uh
two Deweys at the prom
that's high school baby yeah that jammed
them up though oh yeah they had to go
away to like rehab and [__] like that
really yeah rehab yeah sent on a rehab
yikes for like three weeks
right there yeah that's nuts we didn't
have that we had everybody would get
under eight every all of my friends
a good chunk of them were all on
probation in I'm talking like 13 14 15.
really yeah all of them they all got
arrested one night
Busan
smoking weed throwing like
stuff at cars or something
like you know they snuck out of there
all sleeping over someone's house they
all snuck out yeah we're just getting
like you know they were like I think
they were like throwing a hacky sack at
a thing or whatever and got probation
for that we all had we there was like
destruction of property they're 12 13
years old and that there was something
back then see that's the 2000 that's the
difference they were throwing a book at
these kids do they had to do these act
weekends they were called where they
ship you up they would you would take
time off if you did act weekends you
would take time off your probation and
an act weekend was like
you ever see like Maury Povich where
they bring the drill sergeant in and
they [__] like ship them up to the
woods oh Scared Straight yeah they would
send my it's all my boys would go up to
the Poconos for the weekend with like
criminals
like actual criminals like an Outward
Bound kind yes and they'd have to do
like hard labor and like run up
mountains carrying logs and stuff to get
their times like if you if you do a
couple weekends in the labor camps they
let you free yeah very good have a nice
brunch and check out the police
to do a little bird watching that's wild
no yeah so they would do [__] I
remember well it was like eight months
probation or two months probation and
four act week yeah that is the [__]
book and I remember my brother Mike my
boy 13 14 on probation getting shipped
away to go hang out with like
at like 17 year old drug dealers and
stuff yikes and there's a big difference
between a 13 year old and a 17 year old
at that age yikes that's where life it's
like us against NFL guys yeah that's the
same thing yeah they were all like
you've been catching heaters in the
woods and stuff and I remember being
like you are a man that's crazy I
couldn't do that in my best shape oh if
I did it now it'd be bawling my eyes out
oh dude best emotional shots 13 year
olds making fun of me I know you got
your snacks on your phone I wanna go
my stomach hurts somebody else that big
yeah and I remember everybody was they
would get taken out of school how to pee
you know I was used to show up to pick
up my one body always flew too close to
the Sun
always would smoke weed do pills on
probation and then be like I got a call
they're coming Monday and you'd go pick
them up and he'd like walk out with like
a 24 pack of water like to go out for
the night or like two two gallon jugs of
water I gotta flush out till Monday I'm
like
stop smoking weed for a week dude
it's a long time man
fixed
yeah girls come and go though they're
out of the system the pills were it was
always the weed that was jamming people
Jam you up yeah we had something back in
the day I don't know what I never I
don't condone drug use out there
these are all fictional stories stay in
school stay in school yes drink a school
do your milk stay in drugs of course
um all right this one's from Jeff never
have one red is a garbage do yard work
on Christmas it was a 75 degrees one
year on Christmas and my dad made us
rake leaves after we open presents
I ain't nothing worse than that
all your new cool toys are inside and
you're doing yard work on the [__] on
on JC's birthday that's [__] up that
sucks that's the best that's the height
of being a kid do it the next day and
the worst thing of being a kid that's a
dad who hates his job he's just like
this is what this is what the future
holds if I suffer you suffer
they could have done it the next day you
always have the day after Christmas off
yeah but for most people it was nice I
guess they they sprung a nice spring day
on them and they were sure hey tomorrow
it's supposed to rain or something yeah
that's so terrible what doesn't sound
terrible dude imagine opening up all
your new [__] gear you're [__] you
got a Sega you got a new bike whatever
the new hot thing was that you got last
present is a new rake [__]
next one's out in the garage again you
think it's ah that was always a dirt
bike or something
you gotta do that as a parent
no matter what it is you don't gotta you
know you don't gotta [__] break the
bank but you gotta do the [__] all
right that's it I think one more yeah
there's gotta be one more sure I get it
loves it I respect it until it's sucked
and you're like [__]
yeah well I also I'd be feel like
looking back I became like I know
there's one more so that's what I was
looking forward to this is all you got
and I didn't enjoy the moment you know
what I mean I'm like well where's the
where's the dessert you know what I mean
you rush to the young entree to get to
the [__] Goods get through the socks
and batteries yeah oh really okay yeah
uh dragon chain
I think I got it at the Piercing Pagoda
it was called Pure
um
it was the square in the mall in the
middle kiosk now oh like a built yes
that that looks Shady yeah the light it
had like the hospital lights in there
sure yeah it was like free piercing if
you buy the earring man and I knew I
would get my [__] ass some guy who
got fired from Cinnabon some guy some
guy who just got back from an act
weekend
yeah those dudes willing to play it fast
and loose with the legal signature you
know with the with the permission slip
man I remember dude grown man giving
little girls [__] earrings just
blasted needles through teens instead it
was Flawless corn cranking
yikes going to Mr Rags that always
seemed weird all right like my cousin
said go to the mall to get their ears
pierced it would be like a thing yeah
their mom we're gonna take her get her
ears pierced
scared me uh look at one of those guys
you're like I wouldn't let this guy
[__] work the roller coaster
won't let him park the car they were
always Shady they were always like the
guys who like couldn't work at a tattoo
shop or something they had to go to the
mall they had the shakes
hold still I said you're like well I'm
not moving
is it me or is this room spinning
uh yeah I remember dude I wanted a
[__] I think it was from Spencer's or
I knew I could never get my ears pierced
I just knew they wouldn't [__] they
were old school like that no tattoos and
no piercings if you're living in my
house they were real [__] real they
were real [__] You Know Hoodie of the
Air Force they were no dancing in my you
know what I mean like George
Steinbrenner in the 90s they ran a tight
show mustaches and the sideburns
pierced
you better be wearing a thick set of
pants because you're getting your butt
spanked
I did it in college what pierced my ear
but buddy did it
my brother came home with his eye bear
his eyebrow I ever told you the story I
thought he came I think he came home
he came home from was he down in sandals
keep her with his eyebrow and my I'm not
even [__] around him and my dad got
into it and my dad yanked it out of his
[__] head oh right all right off his
face was it a was it a like a hoop yeah
oh man yeah Mr Ryan they were they were
Toe to Toe my brothers I guess thought
he had you know was feeling himself and
my dad knew he still had two three good
ones left in him that was wild uh-huh
that's when I re that was those there
was a year was he like
it didn't strike me that he would be
that kind of kid like into like that
kind of stuff what I don't know I'm
maybe I'm picturing it wrong like I'm
picturing like corn nah this was more
like it wasn't corn it was more like
dork yeah guy trying to be cool
shout out to Gordon
you throw a can of beans at my head [__]
you say [__]
this guy's rocked
uh yeah it was more my boys all went
through a thing in college where they
were getting their tongues pierced
dude I remember
get the [__] out of here with that I
remember a kid in high school that my
brother was friends with had his dick
pierced and everybody knew about my mom
knew him I remember being like this is
weird dude
yeah he had his dick pierced in high
school we used to to the point where he
couldn't drive I'd lose too much real
estate
be like a goddamn door knocker down
there
I couldn't do it it'd be the world's
world's smallest piercing if you look
real close yeah wait yeah I remember
going to pick him up because he used to
get like those things through the no no
stop just stop I can't I can't even put
my [__] I can't start going down that
road I can't get shampoo in there start
freaking out
yeah yeah that's man what a [__] that
was a wacky time back then yeah you
didn't do any of that [__] did you get a
Prince Albert that's what it's called
The Prince Albert
what are your dog
people's got a kettlebell down you know
what I never not London it sounds like
I've not liked but always immediately I
would
if a dude had his nipples pierced that
was a no a no-go for me
I'd be like get out of the pool put that
thing away or [__] this is a
respectable gentleman over here
put baby in a corner no Dirty Dancing
you know he likes to get weird yeah it's
like when I'm 17. relax dude wait till
you grow up a little bit no I respect it
but I just I am I you know as a younger
processor Natalie my mother what a [__]
imagine if magic was a barbecue she
would have shot up the block until I
came home with that Fourth of July you
take your shirt off to jump in the pool
I didn't have to I didn't have the
titties or the nips for that no one does
nah dudes have that if they got like a
good chest I don't got it
that's the kind of guy who takes his
shirt off and puts it in his back pocket
of his jean shorts
and you know who I'm talking about I
love that guy that's all right I could
never pull that off what putting my
shirt in my pocket I can't pull off
taking my shirt off you know what else I
couldn't pull off that I could do it but
I'd hang it over my boobs around my neck
just say this is what I'm doing long
sleeve I got a hoodie
I always wear a scarf in a pool I always
wanted when I was a kid I wanted to rock
that I wanted to rock the uh the sweater
over the shoulder tied up where anywhere
Country Club they get snuck into what do
you mean important meetings there was
nowhere I I wanted that look I in a
world if I could afford the sweaters and
had like to could pull that off sure but
I had nowhere to wear that you know what
I mean like there was no event or
anything I was yeah why'd you bring the
sweater
you know what I mean if you're not gonna
work yeah that's more country call you
know what I mean yeah and the golfers
aren't doing that that was more like the
rich guy is kid just hanging out you
know at the driving range or something
no good yeah picking on the poor kid
that was caddy in there yeah yeah
um you had it and I wanted a tie I
always wanted to tie my uh jacket around
my waist that was cool for when I had a
piece I couldn't do it I just didn't
look right wow we did that with hoodies
was big I want to say I was probably
like 10 or 11 or something like that or
like uh when we were skating hoodies hit
big
Junior high-ish you would do it you know
you would have that that was like still
okay why is it called the Prince Albert
you know I just Googled it man you two
are [__] mind-melding today it's such
a strange name I know it's weird right
did he do it or was there a Prince
Albert that did it Oh you mean the David
Caruso okay
it's so odd Prince Albert was married to
Queen Victoria and it was rumored that
he had his [__] pierced in his 20s
what year is this uh tell me it's the
70s at least no that's probably like the
1800s
1840. that wasn't done at the piercing
but go to I'll tell you that much I'd
give anything to the mall dude
is the piercing free if you bought the
man I'll tell you what I don't know much
that hurt
that hurt and definitely got infected oh
back then they probably did it with a
Rams Horn or something dude all right
hold still
I saw the guy do this one time
rub some butter on it
no kidding freaky Dicky Prince Albert I
mean imagine you you you're married to
the Queen of England and your legacy is
[__] Pierce I would love it if he didn't
have it and he's like guys I swear
seriously that was my butt that was a
joke his buddy's going no it won't stick
don't worry about it won't stick it
won't stick it was a thumb ring I was in
college did you ever do any of that do
you ever do any rings uh colada ring a
lot of ring in a relationship what you
don't know what a collateral we've
talked about it on here I could see you
with like how the [__] do you not know
what a colada ring is how do you spell
that c-o or CA clada c l not a colada
yeah the Irish ring the hands in the
heart
oh I didn't know the name of it oh yeah
you wore that call yourself you're
making fun of me for a dragon necklace
every one of my cousins one of my female
cousins has that I was yeah they have
them for guys they have them for girls
they don't have them for guys yes they
do you wear it you could use it as a
wedding band you wear it when you're in
a relationship that's for chicks you
turn it around if you're engaged that's
for chicks no you're turning it out if
you're a virgin dude yeah yeah dude
that's like
now me and my girlfriend need chadwin
but if you're interested I understand
that you had one but that's for chicks
they made men's I wasn't wearing a girls
it was nice
I was an adult I was in my 20s in your
20s
oh no [__] out of here
I I've no no dude that is the biggest
chick thing in the world that was for
like medieval broad so they could see if
she was on the market or not
trade you for two goats or something try
to make a deal at the pub throw her in
the back yeah no I think you're wrong a
lot of proud Irish Americans wear those
a lot of firefighters a lot of cops
don't try to [__] guilt me in with
the firefighters and the cops
firefighters don't know how to wear
jewelry probably
and they're off time when they're
bartending tendon world needs plenty of
bartenders uh that's a lot of tough guys
have anklets and braided hair the [__]
are you talking yeah okay it's a man's
ring it's a nice thing
I'm not saying they don't wear them yeah
they also Pierce dudes nipples but that
[__] sucks too I'd Rather Have a Prince
album than a colada ring
[__] getting beat up on the subway
[__] out of here dude Prince Albert
rather than a princess Henry
really
nothing I was reading about it I forget
it I was reading about your lady rings
I'm not saying they don't make them for
men for sure they also make charm
necklaces with Dragons but I shouldn't
have been wearing that I had uh 20s I
had one of those I wore that
um
the chain that I have now
which I've had I've had the cross for
25 years maybe 30 years I think I think
I had a ring at some point a ring it was
one like that you would get it on the
boardwalk and like I was probably 12 or
10 or something and like yeah they were
it was like surfer-esque skater Surfer I
would like irony I don't really have the
hands for it I got real uh
bad hands like sausage fingers but I
wouldn't mind a pinky I could do a pinky
I feel like you can't I have my dad's
old ring uh
uh that doesn't fit my regular fingers I
could wear that as a pinky sure it's a
sapphire I could see you in one of those
fist rings that says Hank you know what
I'm saying wait where's all the knuckles
oh yeah whole finger rings yeah and I
don't like that
and I don't know yeah you're not into
the Wu-Tang Clan I don't have movement
in my fingers if I gotta pick a boogie
or something
come in with a black eye Jam you up uh
damn they're like brass knuckles those
things frighten me
brass knuckles
that'll hurt I I think I told the story
I saw a kid get hit with brass knuckles
one time he goes Give Me Your Best Shot
we had a party in a basement big kegger
it was give me your best shot the kid
was from [__] I don't know where he
was from he was somebody's cousin or
something in this [__] scumbag kid
real [__] he's all in [__] clocks
him and he literally just goes like this
and like out of a movie looked back and
then proceed to beat the brakes off the
kid but I go how he goes they wearing
brass knuckles I go how do you know
because they were aluminum or something
because if there was if they were brass
knuckles I wouldn't be here like I
wouldn't be talking to you
and I got my hands on the brass knuckles
and they said like you know 100 aluminum
or whatever I was like you're willing to
roll the dice like that what are you
[__] nuts
it [__] hit the nitrous tank and
relax for a minute
yeah I remember being like what the [__]
he took your dragon away hey
you sir have a good night
yeah nah that was it what about you you
toe ring or anything like that don't
bring no no it wasn't in [__] Cirque
du Soleil
um I said I had a ring uh I had a really
bad watch and I bought a Kmart one year
Young
12 or something like that gold watch oh
you'll hit I had a Mickey watch for a
while in high school a Mickey watch
Mickey Mouse
why because I liked
it matched your vagina what do you mean
because I liked it it was real simple it
was a Mickey Mouse watch with uh with
with a with a leather bag was it like
ironic you had to be a little bit I
don't really know what ironic means I
like I honestly don't I don't know
like as a joke not as a joke but with
like I know this isn't the coolest but
that's what kind of makes it cool a
little bit like when you're wearing
something ironically no I was okay
they weren't cool at the time but I was
wearing it to be cool I think somebody
you're wearing it ironically somebody
wore it in but no I wanted I was wearing
it to look cool yes but you didn't they
weren't of the time you were trying to
be like oh you saw you were trying to
you were trying to be different a little
bit it was like five years after the
time because they were they were popular
I think with like uh
like some of the 80s High School movies
that I liked yes and you're away I can't
put my finger on it I don't feel like
Anthony Michael Hall might have wore one
yeah then you're kind of wearing it
ironically of like I know they're not in
style
and the fact that it's a little
different is kind of cool yeah well I
was trying to be cool though yeah that's
yeah no like all the hipsters are also
trying to be cool wearing you know big
baggy jeans yeah and then that
eventually becomes cool you know what I
mean yeah the Mickey watch the little
hands went around pretty sweet sure all
right yeah other than that no no I had
the necklace a watch I think I tried one
of everything a necklace a watch a ring
hemp necklaces for a while I would make
them too
yeah my buddy from California told me
how to make them I'm sure I've asked you
as this but just so we can all move
forward
neither one he ever wore Patchouli right
no Toby never
Toby is like anti-hippy but still very
close to hippie I [__] hate hippies
that's what hippies say yeah it's a real
hippie thing to say take it easy Nixon
will you
you smell Patchouli that's how you know
a robbery is gonna happen why because
they're dirty thieves I always
identified that smell with like the
Grateful Dead people no it's a smell of
sticky handed [__] who are here for
your goods that didn't [__] makes me
nauseous
crazy yeah it's not my cup of tea baby
smell Patchouli or opium you're in a bad
place I gotta keep this vague but some
real cool spot someone in my life
rocks it
at the moment at the moment an older
person I only see them once in a while
at extended extended gatherings
and when that rolls through
yeah it's like [__] drop my shrimp
cocktail one of the three wise men kick
rocks will you
walking around kicking myrrh take your
[__] frankincense out but speaking of
which I'm out of my cologne I gotta find
a new scent I was thinking Sandalwood
how about
Can't Believe It's Not Butter
I was thinking Sandalwood
you act like I can just pull Sandalwood
Johnny D's got that Savage looks pretty
nice I don't know what any of those
words mean Johnny Depp
if you show up with leather straps
around your wrist I'm gonna be real
upset you can't be doing five scarves
bankrupt
shout out to death
um I wanted one of those what so bad one
of those like leather things when I was
like I'm my buddy rocked one I want to
say like high school-ish one or two of
my dad's boys the guys that weren't
married they would roll in with like two
three turquoise rings and one of those
with their watches turquoise you can
kick Rock every Rock that's ever out go
to the Quarry find every rock ever and
[__] kick them it's never been cool
it always rubbed me the wrong way too
you look like a witch or something
go back to your stew or your cauldron I
don't we're not hanging with your
turquoise a necklace sure if you keep a
Darkly a little stone or something but
like the big stainless steel Native
Americans of course that's your heritage
but if your name's Steve and you're from
Idaho yeah lose the [__] Ozzy
Osbourne hands I'll give you a little
turquoise and a bolo tie if you're from
the you know from the southwest yeah
that's of the elk I'll give you that but
if you yeah yeah Arizona gets a pass yes
the region gets a pass it's very of the
of the of the rejones sure it's very
dependent on the quality of queso in
your area it's like jean shorts and
jersey I'll give you a pass
can I see the chef please
the quality it gates up man I still
can't get over that colada ring or
whatever it's called
I'm telling you man a lot of [__]
I don't know one I'm not saying you're
wrong I don't know I know a lot of dirt
somebody in your family has to have had
every Broad
Catherine Bridget Jenny all wore them no
dude ever wore one of those in my life
that I know
all right I'm a [__] all right there we
go at least we have closure on the side
uh yeah this ain't news hey newsflap man
ozympic really does change your man yeah
yeah
uh yeah I'm not saying people don't wear
them I'm sure I just I I don't think
they're maybe as popular as your
painting
that's all all right uh I was gonna get
you one for Christmas A colada ring
uh-huh would you wear it
uh no
no I would give it to a lady it's a cool
story it means something a hand and a
heart something like that I can't
remember what it was yeah so cool you
forgot it huh yeah
over there finger popping yourself
that's where it is let's keep it warm uh
all right let's see this one's from
Scott B is it garbage have a computer
chair at the kitchen table
oh yeah off look that's
depends on I'll give you an age an age
for sure however after 25 later but late
90s early 2000s those [__] things
were everywhere A Lot the big computer
oh yeah yeah I mean they were they were
in every room they were in odd places I
feel like this is a computer deployed
those on the front lines those things
they were [__] everywhere yeah I feel
like the computer growing up was in
very odd places in the homes living room
it was in the living room a lot of time
we put ours in the basement
there you go
uh
some type of early warning system a
couple of couple of glass bottles at the
top of the stairs of that door opened
hey
I'm talking to dudes pretending to be
late
I might have done that
who are also pretending to be ladies
that was huge Man ASL baby
age sex location
get in there and get weird
uh I we had kitchen or a kitchen chair
uh computer chair in college was
furniture
yeah we had two computer chairs in the
living room that like could move around
yeah you would sit you'd have to get up
yeah how many Bernies I caught on a
computer chair just watching a TV a lot
of them get a nice one from Staples I
was doing all right until the wheel goes
then there was always the real cheap
version of them that like they were like
real small plastic the wheel always win
didn't turn didn't go up or down anymore
we had one in our apartment when me and
my brother were living together and over
like three years the arms fell off so we
got rid of them then the back fell off
we got rid of that it was just like a
stool
some real bad seat that's what it turns
into okay you threw a game though all
right
um
all right let's see how this one's from
Ricky dock
is a garbage to use your mom's bank card
to pay ayg patreon subscriptions at 33
years old
buddy you gotta do you gotta keep the
plate spinning and that's part of it let
someone else pass you know hey
oh yeah man that's a tough look but
thank you for your service I appreciate
it you're really doing thank your mom
too yeah
yeah it's not ideal
it's not ideal but you gotta do what you
gotta do don't act like you haven't
moved some funds around got the cash in
your mom's hand them how to use her card
buddy not hating at all in the not too
distant past not hating at all I'm
that's why I'm wrapping my head around
it I totally get it yeah I did I just
got my first credit card [__] two
years ago daddy wasn't a big credit card
person uh we charged everything
everything
there was a good chunk of year so I'm
sure there was a mountain of credit card
debt and the piece going charging to the
game charging to the game and she would
probably throw about a 100 to 120 bucks
a month at it just kicking that game
down and raved
dude
[Music]
shoebox full of bills I thought my mom
made minimum payments so much that I
thought that was [__] just what you
did yeah
yeah that was it yeah
tell us until they [__] survived
um yeah big minimum payment big minimum
payment household
which now I can't I try to pay
everything
because I'm so bad that I know I'd I'll
lose control at some point
so I'm like trying to stay ahead of it
I'm trying to pay everything on time
because I I'm I've never historically
been able to stay above
I've never been able to stay afloat sure
so I'm just [__] I'm really trying to
get out in front of everything
um all right this one's from Tim this
just says can you do uh we could do it
on the patreon could you do an episode
of the wild wonderful Whites of West
Virginia you've seen of course you
probably haven't the documentary about
the the inbred family that lives there
yeah the one guy barks well I don't know
I mean maybe I don't remember oh I
remember all drug addicts that live off
of that all like that live on loopholes
where they like West Virginia pays the
money or something one of the greatest
moments ever captured captured on video
is that guy shaking that bottle of pills
going this is a Boone County mating call
yeah
if only come fully comes in the shot
hello stranger
sure yeah
yeah but what if you haven't watched
that [__] you go [__] watch that
what do they want us to do they just
said talk about it but uh we could do
like we should probably go down there
but we should do we could do which we've
never done we have to figure it out
technical wise but like a watch along
yeah we could do that you know what I
mean yeah you just uh yeah like a
commentary type thing would you pause it
I don't know before that is like that's
[__] garbage that's
that's that's not even fun garbage
that's just insane trash
for copyright purposes we could do like
a sync up thing maybe have a counter on
the bottom that says where we're at in
the thing uh showing that at a bar and
that's how they got everybody on the
[__] pay-per-view back in the day
yeah I still I'll still go to I'll still
I've still watch fights in the recent
future or the recent past the recent
future of going to a bar you pay 20
bucks and they just have it on a
computer have you ever bought a
pay-per-view that to me you have to be a
millionaire to do that never we did yeah
never I wouldn't even know how to do it
oh well back in the day
you called you had to call I remember
those days but then once on demand came
you could just press order they would
show the first like the first two fights
uh like boxing matches I would watch it
with my dad but there's one like Lennox
Lewis was the heavyweight never he would
fight with Klitschko right or
klitschkoff the big Russian dude there
was two brothers yeah
um I remember getting a couple of those
the mayor in Ukraine uh is he yeah bam
uh I would get a couple of like the
wrestlemanias we got
but that was it it was a big wrestling
buff sure uh man never but they were
never I think it was always under the
guise of I had nuts I had to pay for
that you'd be I had to be run out of
time you're chased out of the house what
a hundred dollars no they were never a
hundred bucks these were like 49.99 the
wrestling was it could have been a
billion it didn't matter sure my but I
always had the the thing was I always
had to pay for it ah really yeah where'd
you get the money dragon
I was running the streets no it was like
you know with your birthday money I mean
I would go to work with my dad and [__]
I would get you know here's 20 40.
anytime I would make I had to pay for
all that [__] anytime I would make that
move not on a pay-per-view but if like
later if I would order something
on demand or whatever get a movie that
you're paying that when it comes in
I still later my step that would hit me
with a bill was like highlighted charges
like yeah yeah take it out of the
[__] allowance will you
go to the pub
13. yeah
I'll be at the bar if you need me
dusting off
that was his line I'm gonna go down the
street and dust off a bit Wet My Whistle
wait your whistle was bad you can wet
your whistle that's what my dad always
said I was allowed to have like a sip of
water because I'd always pee the bed can
wet your whistle
yeah I would pee the bed what of it yeah
I know all about it uh
um okay uh all right let's do a couple
more uh this one's just good this is
from Nick 20 shareholder shout out to
you sir shout out to him uh is it
garbage dip your Little Caesar's crazy
bread pizza into Pepsi and then eat it
here's the thing with this I'm a biting
sip so I get to that we get to the same
conclusion just different styles
you're looking at me like I'm crazy no
I'm just picked that's like Joey
Chestnut [__] that's yeah competitive
eater movement bite and sip like a
gentleman there's there's okay
the slightly less offensive version of
this is french fries in a milkshake of
course Pizza Savory Swedish I'll give
you that pizza crust dipped in a sodi is
good
it's real it's real but then I don't I I
couldn't for me 12 13. I can't change I
can't drink the soda there's like an oil
slick it looks like the Exxon Valdez
yeah it's not perfect there's sauce and
stuff it's like just do the mixing in
your mouth where it mixes yeah mix it in
the mix hole I'm just trying to explain
it to you and I I get it I've done it
I've been a fan I understand I'm not uh
it's not for me I'm saying it's not for
me for that reason I also at one time
was was letting the pizza get somewhat
cold taking all the cheese off in one
thing rolling that up eating it and then
eating the the dough by itself they're
just like
an artist trying to do stuff differently
I just wanted that straight hit a
[__] mozzarella
and it was worth having to eat the pizza
because my mom would freak out
with what because I was wasting it she's
like you're eating that wait you would
just eat the cheese at some point at
first I would peel the cheese off and
then roll it off with a burn victim man
that's a the undercarriage of a of a
[__] that ain't supposed to see the
light of day
that's that's I mean man wasn't meant to
see this no it's real weird yeah I mean
I don't mind it but as a little kid it
looks like it's healing yeah scabbing up
I just ripped up he just ripped off the
protective layer of epidermis and it's
real it's a real it's a real interesting
texture underneath that yeah it's slimy
it's like a caterpillar
yeah it's not for me
yeah but to me and Alex would just cram
it the whole thing in his face you're
really taking your time with it
I feel like Reservoir Dogs cutting an
ear off and dancing around and I keep it
in a well
yeah it puts the mozzarella on uh all
right this one's from a little Goosey
are you garbage if you live in a motel
full time my uncle lived in a place that
would rent that had hourly rentals
listen I don't that's how it ain't great
it's not classy but those you're doing
what you gotta do to survive to not be
on the street I presume
it's probably pretty nice nice turn down
service ice machine a motel he said with
hourly rates
bed and this guy's jammed up that's what
I'm saying
yeah I'm not hating on a guy who's doing
what he's got to do it's no good maybe
he's running work out of there I don't
know sure I mean you know he said hey
he's doing I'd rather that or he's
sleeping on a street or in a car so I
get real creeped out in the extended
stay hotels we've been in a couple of
those with a little kitchenette
they're good and bad they're good and
bad I just when you're in an extended
stay motel
you're more you which ain't great right
you're dirtier you're doing stuff that
you shouldn't be doing
and then I go what was the guy doing in
this kitchen before me making eggs with
no underwear on probably doing a little
crying yeah it just ain't great and it's
just it just for sure I don't like
sleeping in a room where someone's
cooked Ramen yeah that's what I'm saying
it's like stay out of my place there's
two
laughs
I'm knocking on my door sailor I'll tell
you that there's too much in every room
in that house
just walking around a microwave
uh there's too much business someone can
get into that just goes like what are
they doing with the spatula the only
thing about the motel is it's usually I
picture that on the first floor and it
opens out to the street yeah that's a
motel yeah yeah I'm not I thought this
uncle's like this is the ideal situation
of course everything in an Extended Stay
feels like it's been inside of a human
yes that's what I'm saying like they're
probably the guy's whipping himself with
the spatula who knows what those Forks
have been that's what I'm saying those
Forks have definitely scratched a couple
backs yeah
or something love a fork you ever use a
fork to scratch your back no dude it's
nice
nice yeah sure I can just see you just
rip letting that rip and just right back
no never he gets a wipe on the leg
on his dirty underwear and then back in
he's not an animal I let the dog lick it
a little bit get a little spit shine
no never but I have I've used it I I
have eaten been done and then scratched
my back with a dirty fork and then put
it in the dishwasher
yeah well I mean it's not ideal as you
said a [__] pasta sauce on your back
let's see that's not ideal at all what
is it for the depthness or the reach or
both it's for the sharpness yeah like
the you get in there man really [__]
we're chasing the dragon so to speak I
love a back scratcher let me just get
one I don't know lazy okay I got that
fork
I got a whole drawer for they keep
spawning in there uh we gotta wrap it up
gang ah gang this was a fun one oh yeah
I'm gonna tell you this we love you see
you next week